[Music]
that's here our car tester Android
Zimmerman has the key to a renault clio
it has the format of a fat credit card
he's not impressed with its workmanship
so he wonders if the car itself is more
well-intentioned and well-made that's
really hard tomorrow's finding renault
has clearly done a good job
environmentally speaking the Clio with
the DC i-90 engine emits only 95 grams
of co2 per kilometer the ancient puts
out 66 kilowatts and deluxe version the
Clio starts at 18,500 euros in Germany
it did see the Clio's DC i-90 engine is
a real fuel miser says Andre since it's
a diesel you can dry with low revs
achieving fuel consumption rates with a
3 in front of the decimal point good
technology is one thing the human factor
the other and the most important when it
comes to saving fuel and Renault is
aware of that our car tester says the
Clio helps the driver take full
advantage of the diesel engine savings
potential a luminous strip on the
instrument panel shows green when you
drive with good fuel efficiency but
moves through orange to red if you don't
you can also view statistics on the
monitor that help you analyze and
improve your gear shifting and
accelerating no common tasks on certain
ohana Luciano design fast to focus on so
make use of your momentum and avoid
unnecessary acceleration and
deceleration of course the Clio is not a
sports car but it's very safe the
European new car assessment program gave
it five stars Andre is impressed with
the Clio's interior especially in the
looks version the materials are
high-quality and stylish and the overall
design is very modern but Andre thinks
there's too much piano finish especially
on the steering wheel he'd prefer it
entirely in leather
rather than having piano finish trim
which tends to show dust and
fingerprints those who want to keep
their Clio looking clean should pack a
microfiber cloth or duster Frankish
Canada EMAS when Nico father talked
about Soha
so the elegant appearance has its
disadvantages the Clio suspension is
more sporty than comfortable you
definitely feel a bumpy road the shift
feels a bit squishy and the steering
could give better feedback to
[Music]
a car Chester says the Clio's large
outside mirrors provide a good overview
of what's happening in back the Clio
looks great from the outside dynamic
round forms the daytime running lights
are integrated in the radiator grille
the rear door handle is optically
concealed the trunk has enough space but
it's floor is anything but flat the
engineers ought to correct that Andre
says the designers wanted to make the
Clio sportier with Kupe light lines but
that left the c-pillar too big when you
glance over your shoulder the blind spot
is rather large of course important
vinca as we said the interior is very
elegant but requires corresponding care
the climate control and the display in
the middle are easily surveyed and
operated
[Music]
the seats are good-looking and
comfortable but offer no lateral support
leather and heated seats come only with
the more expensive GT and sport packages
at 18,500 euros that Clio is not a
bargain says Andre but you do get
something for your money inside and out
and the Clio is very environmentally
friendly but Andre liked it a lot better
in the front seat the back seat ought to
be roomy enough on short trips and
people shorter than 1 metre 75 will feel
ok there for longer periods if you don't
need the elegant interior credit card
key and leather steering wheel you can
settle for the dynamic version and save
about 1200 euros in Germany it comes
with the same fuel efficient engine
you